mark wahlberg and mel gibson have joined
forces to tell the true story of a
roustabout fighter who literally smashes
into his higher calling our own raymond
arroyo interviewed the filmmakers in l.a
raymond aren't you lucky
laura father stu is a faith-based film
like no other wahlberg gibson and writer
director rosalind ross told me in this
ingram angle exclusive what sets it
apart and they gave us a glimpse of the
chemistry that makes it so powerful
watch there's no biography of father stu
there's a lot of articles people
remember him i've read some interviews
about him so you were dealing with scant
material that you're trying to build a
life out of how much liberty did you
take and where did you draw that line
the basic framework of his life um
and you know the trajectory of
his um
spirituality is all
true um we we did take liberties
especially with regard to time frame for
example he studied
you know in oregon and he went to france
and he was sort of all over the place
but you can't do all that you can't do
all that no um and not with our budget
it doesn't show dig at me it doesn't
show
seems like it's a you know it was a
no-brainer it was a very uh stressful
decision at the time
it was tiger but you know that's the
beauty of it i mean there's art and i
think those are all the you get the best
results and you know kind of being you
know under 10. yes under the gun it's
like it's just you know you're all kind
of forced we had what seemed like
forever to get to the starting gate then
we had to rush 30 days to shoot the
movie and then 30 days what seemed like
a long time to cut the movie and now we
are here we are again chasing a release
date so it's just one of those things
you've been road testing this i know
you've been taking it on the road what
are they telling you first of all
you know people have been overwhelmed by
the movie everybody has some sort of
personal connection to it something that
they're it just drums up something that
they've experienced in their own life
that's very very touching to them um
even the most cynical of people
especially i was talking to a couple
journalists and i was like this movie
will touch you in some sort of personal
way yeah journalists are cynical people
and they're like whatever
not all of them but this these two in
particular and right away they came up
to me like oh my god one guy hadn't
talked to his dad they've been estranged
for quite some time he texted him once
he walked out of the theater his dad
texted him right back they were having
lunch that next day
and another journalist who had suffered
a loss and she was kind of thought she
was over it passed it and really just
touched them were you here to visit sir
father steven
you and everybody else
we shouldn't pray for an easy life
but the strength to endure a difficult
one
[Music]
well you can't say i never gave you
nothing yeah i skipped over thanking you
went straight to the source this is
about a family in crisis
father stu has a story but you really
could have called this father stu and
bill i mean it really is about the
healing of a father-son relationship and
a family coming together unexpectedly
through pain and suffering talk to me
about
that suffering theme
and the value and redemptive value of
suffering and mel i'll start with you
because you know a little about this um
cinematically and maybe personally
because i mean this is a territory you
know well oft times i thought you know
when things are going great and you're
on the easy street that's when you're
kind of lax about who you are and you
make you make mistakes and you can
you know your character flaws come to
the fore it's when you're in crisis
somehow
that you're able to pull the better
parts of yourself out to deal with
um you know big problems like and
and you know uh it's it's about
suffering really i mean all of us are
dragging some kind of boulder some kind
of cross you know
uh in some aspect of our lives and it's
like uh
it's when it's when we're dealing with
that stuff i think that we're our best
and that was certainly the case with
father stu i mean he became his best
through suffering having gratitude as a
whole is really important but i think
you know everybody's having lots of
difficulties it's it's in all those
difficulties when i focused on my faith
i was able to endure and good things
started to happen and
everything seemed to make sense it
certainly made it easier and and gave me
a lot of comfort and people have been
people have been going through a lot and
i think the the thing that people
are all experiencing is that they're
reminded you know that they need to have
faith and hope and that uh you know
love will endure so
well and it's the perfect time i mean
holy week it becomes it's a moment of
kind of reflection for so many people
they're buying out theaters they're
going as a group because they want to
kind of experience this as one which
again rings bells for you and as long as
we're ringing bells
you are doing lethal weapon 24 years
since the last one and almost 19 years
since the passion mill and you're going
back to donnerville
how did that happen well
yeah you're making me feel like i think
they're going to call it flaccid weapon
right but uh we'll wait that release
yeah okay but uh
the yeah i'm going back there it's a
it's great territory unfortunately
donner's not with us to kind of uh helm
that production he passed away but uh
he kind of passed the torch of me before
he left and uh uh and uh as a tribute to
him could i love the guy i made six
films with him so i'm
i'm um actually it's an honor for me to
to take the the reigns on that one and
do it okay uh what did you all give up
for lent oh i tried to give up
complaining but it hasn't worked out so
well
and um i'm trying to sort of pull my
waistline in by being a little more
obstinous in my eating habits
oh boy rose would you give up for lent i
didn't give up anything you need to give
something
suffer with the rest of us it doesn't
matter rose i know a lot of non-catholic
people they should suffer too much
okay i'm done
again i'm trying to be a little bit more
forward thinking instead of giving up
something and complaining about it i'm
just trying to do more trying to do
better trying to continue to promote
stu's message so many more people are
hearing his message and you know and
he's touching them what do you want
people to focus on as they watch this
movie particularly everybody's going to
everybody's going to get something
different but everybody's going to be
touched by it
it's unavoidable we're all going through
so much we're all dealing with so much
and uh it just uh it just reminds us you
know that uh
how you handle these things and stu
handles it with such grace and
film dignity it really is yeah father
stew hits theaters april 13th or we're
going to air the second part of that
interview with mel and mark and rose
next week stay tuned for that all right
raymond great interview i cannot wait to
see this film and it sounds like i need
it this time this time of lent thank you
so much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else